I was the public financial services but
I was worked with more in the state for
many years and he's been a great talent
here it's a pleasure to be here today
we're in Syracuse
State University Upstate Medical School
and Hospital I had a chance to say hello
to the horses and doctors who work here
at the way from social distance but I
wanted to say thank you for all they've
done here you also sent a team down to
New York City so it's just been an
extraordinary experience but I've seen
the good the bad and the ugly you know
all of this and the good is beautiful
let me talk to you about some of the
facts that we're dealing with today
facts are our friend right people want
to make decisions they want to know the
facts without a spin without opinion and
that's what we'll be giving them total
hospitalization rate is down a tick
which is good news the change in
hospitalization on a rolling total you
see is down number of intubations is
also down the number of cold lead
hospitalizations per day these are new
people who are newly diagnosed with
kovat it's under 1,000 which is good
news it's still a significant number of
people 900 people after all of this we
still have 900 more infections yesterday
on a three day rolling average but
overall you see the numbers coming down
so that's good news this is the worst
bonus every day I think maybe today's
the day the nightmare will be over but
it's not
335 people passed away yesterday from
this virus in this state that's 335
families you see this number is
basically reducing
but not at a tremendous rate and the
only thing tremendous is the number of
New Yorkers who still pass away everyone
is talking about reopening I get it you
can't sustain enclosed the economy can
still sustain it individual families
can't sustain it we can't sustain it on
a personal level our children can't
sustain it but we have to when we talk
about reopening this should not be a
political discussion shouldn't be a
philosophical discussion shouldn't be
because people are protesting or some
people want it some people don't want it
it is a factual discussion on reopening
right so let's demystify it a little bit
because in this environment it's
becoming rhetorical rather than factual
we want to reopen but we want to do it
without infecting more people or
overwhelming the hospital system weird
upstate medical today our great fear was
the number of people infected would
overwhelm the hospital capacity so
that's the balance reopen but don't
increase the number of infected people
and don't overwhelm the hospital system
well then design that system in
reopening right you can you can
factually with data design a system that
does just that and that's what
government is supposed to do government
is not about spouting on political or
philosophical opinions government is
about running services designing
programs that actually work for the
people to address the problem and in
this situation we can actually measure
we have data we have facts so measure
what is happening in society and
calibrate your reopening to those
measurements right so we're adopting us
rules a set of guidelines we've studied
reopening plans or on the country we've
spoken to every expert on the globe
who's been through this before and we've
come up with factual data points to
guide us on reopening first point don't
over one the hospital system if the
hospital system in an area exceeds
seventy percent capacity which means
you're thirty percent you only have
thirty percent left or the rate of
transmission of the virus hits one point
one those are danger signs we know that
remember hospital capacity if you're
seventy percent on your hospitals
there's a two-week lag on this virus so
if you ever hit seventy percent you can
expect the number to go up for the next
two weeks as people become who just got
infected actually get ill and some of
them come into the hospitals so seventy
percent is a safe metric to use for your
hospital capacity if the transmission
rate hits one point one that's what they
call outbreak that means it's going to
spread much much faster
you wouldn't start reopening unless you
had a transmission rate below point one
point one really below one but if it
hits one point one that means you're in
trouble so those are the two main data
points if you look at the state and this
state is different than most states this
state has New York City one of the most
dense urban areas on the globe and then
we have upstate New York and if you look
at our infection rate upstate New York
it's very different than the rate
downstate in New York and if you look at
the rate upstate New York it's
comparable to many states in the Midwest
and the West we hear the discussion
every day
some states are reopening because they
don't have that better problem some of
the places in upstate have a problem
that's comparable to states in the
Midwest or the West much much different
than New York City okay then let's come
up with data points factual points of
what we have to do to reopen so everyone
has the same opening template that we're
dealing with and we have to be smart
about this again I know it's a motion
and I know people are feeling emotional
but emotions can't drive a reopening
process right we're talking about
infection rates we're talking about
hospital capacity separate the emotion
from the logic and we have to act as our
logical selves here and that's what
smart means be smart about it don't be
emotional don't be political don't get
pushed politically into a situation
protestors are in front of the Capitol
we better reopen no I'm not going to do
that that's not how we make decisions
the first point is CDC set guidelines as
to reopening four states we think those
CDC guidelines make sense which is you
have to have a 14 day decline in the
number of hospitalizations before you go
forward second identify industries that
you can start reopening that will bring
people back to work get the economy
going but you know you can do the
appropriate precautions and social
distancing so in phase one we're talking
about the construction and manufacturing
industry right those are two industries
that employ a lot of people but we
believe you can put the right
precautions in place and learn the
lessons from where we have been and say
to those businesses this is not just
about government saying that the
businesses tell us how you are going to
incorporate the lessons that we just
learned how do you incorporate social
distancing
you incorporate fewer people in the
space so you reduce density how do you
have the right PPE how are you going to
monitor or you can take temperatures of
everyone who walks in that's for
businesses to decide also separate point
make sure you don't have what we call
attractive nuisance nuisances not really
the right use of the term attractive
nuisance is a legal term but an
attractive nuisance in this context you
open up a facility or an attraction that
could bring people from outside the
region to you you have all this pent-up
demand and the whole tri-state region
make sure you don't open up something
that's going to bring hundreds of people
from the outside in
what business precautions will those
individual businesses take watch the
healthcare capacity your health care
system cannot go over seventy percent
capacity again there's a two-week lag if
you're 70 percent bells should go off
don't go over 70 percent in your ICU
beds many of the people who come in with
kovat need an ICU bed because it's a
respiratory illness as a matter of fact
almost at the heat of this almost every
bed in a hospital turns into an ICU bed
that's why we needed the ventilators
because these people who get seriously
ill with kovat need that level of care
remember you have a flu season coming up
in the fall and the number of
hospitalizations normally goes up in the
flu season so anticipate that stockpile
the equipment we've learned a lot of
painful lessons here one is you have to
have the PPE you have to have the masks
you have to have the gown there's an
international demand on it so make sure
we have a stockpile of reserve of the
PPE we have to have testing how many
tests dr. Burks recommends 30 per 1,000
people different people different
rekka have different numerical
percentages but i think we start with
that
do we have enough testing sites how long
does it take to turn around the test and
then are we advertising to people this
is where you go and this is what you do
to get a test if you think you may be
infected the whole thing with keeping
that infection rate down is find a
person early who was infected let them
know it and then trace and then isolate
do we have a tracing system in place
Mayor Bloomberg is helping us organize
this it's never been done before nobody
ever heard of tracing to this extent but
tracing is once a person says they're
positive you trace their contacts back
you notify people you test people that's
a whole different operation the current
recommendation is you need at least 30
tracers per 100,000 people so we have to
have that in place you have to have
isolation facilities in place isolation
facilities are when someone gets sick
you know they're positive and they don't
want to go home to quarantine because if
they go home they could infect their
family which is what's happening now a
lot of these new cases so we have to
have a facility where somebody who is
positive can quarantine for the two
weeks without going home and we have to
identify them now we have to coordinate
regionally the schools transportation
nets network testing tracing this all
has to be coordinated on a multi-county
effort we have to reimagine telemedicine
reimagine tell education we have to have
a regional control room that is
monitoring all these indicators and
gives us the danger sign if we get over
70% capacity if the infection rate pops
up we have to have one central source
that's monitoring all these dials that
hits the danger button so you could
actually slow down the
opening and then we have to protect and
respect essential workers which I'll
talk about in a moment on business is
they have to have social distancing
continued testing ongoing monitoring
protocols that's all part of the new
normal and businesses are going to have
to do that if they want to reopen
they're going to have to adopt the
federal and the state guidelines on this
issue today we're announcing a an
advisory board that is made up of
statewide business leaders academic
leaders civic leaders who's advising us
on just this and they have been for
weeks and I want to thank them very much
manufacturing construction as the first
phase businesses that's 46,000 jobs in a
place like central New York so it's a
major employer and these are businesses
that can adopt to the new normal in
terms of the their employees in terms of
the places of business and in terms of
the processes that they put in place on
the healthcare capacity again we just
live this we cannot be in a situation
where 70% capacity is exceeded you need
at least that 30% buffer on hospital
beds and you need 30% of your ICU beds
available if that number starts to tick
up in terms of testing we have to have
the testing regimen in place and we have
to prioritize the people who get tested
symptomatic people individuals who came
in contact with a symptomatic person and
frontline and essential workers they do
have a higher rate of infection because
they're putting themselves in harm's way
and we want to make sure they have the
testing so we have an early alert system
you have to have the right number of
sites testing won't work if it's
impossible to get testing won't work if
it's too hard to get so you have to have
the right number of sites for the area
that you're dealing with the advertising
is very important it has to be available
but people have to know it's available
and they have to know what the symptoms
are
that would have them go get tested
because again this is about people
understanding it and people buying into
it this is not government orders this is
people get it they know the facts they
know what they're supposed to do and
they do it because they have been we've
communicated successfully the
circumstances and the facts but you need
that testing and you need it to trace
the contacts otherwise you see that
infection rate increase on the tracing
the estimate is thirty tracers for every
100,000 people so that's a data point
that's what it means to have tracing in
place and then isolation facilities is a
proportion number of people who test
positive who say I can't go home or I
don't want to go home I don't want to
infect my family I don't want to infect
my significant other I have enough
issues without having to explain how I
infected my significant other with Kovac
we develop point so isolation facilities
available for those people and then the
regional control room where you're
monitoring all of those metrics you're
monitoring Hospital capacity the rate of
infection the PPE burn rate how
businesses are complying and it has an
emergency switch that we can throw if
any one of those indicators are
problematic because remember we have
gone through hell and back over the past
60 or so days what we've done has been
tremendous really tremendous and what
people have done what the American
people have done what New Yorkers have
done has been to save lives literally
but we have to remain vigilant this is
not over I know as much as we want it to
be over it's not over and we have to
respect what we accomplished here when
they started this the projections for
this state
120,000 New Yorkers would be infected
and hospitalized only 20,000 were
infected and hospitalized how could they
be so wrong they weren't wrong we
changed reality the differential the
variance is what we did
it's the closed-down it's wearing masks
it's all of that we've reduced the rate
we so-called flatten the curve flatten
the curve well that meant 100 thousand
fewer New Yorkers didn't get seriously
ill didn't go into a hospital then
overwhelm the hospital system and a
percentage of those people who got
seriously ill would have passed away so
we literally saved lives we can't now
negate everything that we accomplished
we have to do the opposite we have to
take this experience and we have to
learn and grow from the experience and
we have to build back better than before
as a society and as a community we need
better systems this exposed a lot of
issues fundamental issues we have to do
a better job on tella
education remote learning sounds great
but you have to have all the equipment
people have to be trained and teachers
have to be trained we jumped into it we
have to do a better job we have to do a
better job on telemedicine not everybody
has to show up at the doctor's office
you can do a better job we have to do a
better job on our basic public health
system I mean when you look back the
virus was in China last November and
December last November in December why
didn't someone suspect
well maybe the virus gets on a plane
last November December and lands in the
United States the next day right
everybody talks about global
interconnection and how fast you
everybody knows there's a a virus in
China last November
December China says don't worry we're
taking care of it yeah but all you need
is one person to get on a plane as it
happened one person got on the plane and
went from China to Europe and then it
went from Europe to New York
the flights from China basically go to
the west coast two flights from Europe
basically go to the east coast we got it
through Europe but where was the whole
international health community where was
the whole national host of experts the
w-h-o the NIH the CDC that old alphabet
soup of agencies where was everyone
where were the where was the
intelligence community with the
briefings saying this is in China and
they have something called an aeroplane
and you can get on an aeroplane and you
can come to the United States governor's
don't do global pandemics right
but there's a whole international
national health community would do that
we're all the experts where was the New
York Times where was the Wall Street
Journal where was all the bugle blowers
who should say be careful there's a
virus in China that may be in the United
States that was November December we're
sitting here January February still
debating how serious this is
and again it's not a state
responsibility but in this system who
was supposed to blow the bugle and
didn't because I would Bank that this
happens again and is the same thing
going to happen again I hope not
so we have to figure these things out we
also have to remember that as a society
and as a community we're about
government - we're about systems but
even more we are about values what makes
us who we are are our values and that's
my last point which is point number 12
protect and respect the essential
workers I had two nightmares when this
started one that I would put out
directives on what we need to do and 19
million New Yorkers would say I haven't
been convinced I'm not going to do this
just look at what the directives were
we're gonna close down every business
you have to stay in your home I mean the
most disruptive government policies put
in place I can't even remember the last
time I don't know I can't even see in
the history books the last time
government was more disruptive to
individual life no businesses everybody
stays home no schools
what happens if New Yorkers said we're
not doing that
we're not doing that it's too much it's
an overreaction it's political cuz
everything's political nowadays right so
easy to say well that's just political
that was a fear because if New Yorkers
did that governmental II had no ability
to enforce 19 million people staying in
their homes that's why the communication
was so important give them the facts
give them the facts give them the facts
so they understand why that worked
second nightmare was what if the
essential workers don't show up you have
to have food you have to have
transportation the lights have to be on
someone has to pick up the garbage the
hospitals have to run what if the
essential worker said I'm not showing up
you've communicated so effectively the
fear of the virus that the essential
workers say yeah if everybody's staying
home I'm staying home too it could have
happened I went through the HIV virus
when HIV started people were petrified
nobody knew what it was that nobody knew
how it how it lived
was transferred how long it lived people
were petrified nobody wanted to go near
it what happens if the essential workers
here said I'm not gonna show up to run
the bus you don't pay me enough to put
my life in danger I'm not doing it they
showed up they showed up
I just finished communicating how
dangerous this was to convince 19
million people to stay home and close
schools and close businesses and the
essential workers still showed up that
is a value they didn't show up for a
paycheck they didn't show up because
government asked them to show up they
didn't show up because their employer
said I need you to show up they showed
up out of their values and out of their
honor and out of their dignity that's
why they showed up
my grandfather people know my father in
this state my grandfather little Italian
immigrant aundrea Cuomo named for him no
education [ __ ] digger came here the
classic immigrant story winds up having
a little grocery store in South Jamaica
Queens poor community and during the
Depression he almost lost the store and
he'd love to tell the story why did he
almost lose the store well it was the
depression and the finances no because
he gave away food during the Depression
because he wouldn't let anyone be hungry
so a family would come in nobody had
money was there depression and he would
give them food and he was giving away so
much food that he had problems paying
his bills gave him a lot of stress wound
up having a heart attack as a young
person but no one told him to do that
that was just his van
use and I would ask him about it
afterwards I said grandpa why would you
he said what up what am I going to do
let them go hungry I'm gonna I'm gonna
let somebody go hungry
I was unimaginable to him he was an
essential worker nobody called him an
essential worker but he was an essential
worker and that's what people are doing
day in and day out here the person who
delivers the groceries the person was
driving the bus the person was driving
the subway the nurses the doctors the
orderlies all these people who are
showing up every day not because of the
check they could stay home to and file
for unemployment no they're doing it out
of their sense of honour and their sense
of dignity and their sense of pride that
this is their mission this is their role
their New Yorkers they're Americans and
they're going to show up the police
officers the firefighters I mean
everyone's petrified you want to be a
police officer you're gonna pull people
over in a car you're gonna go into a
house for a domestic disturbance wrestle
with somebody in the house you don't
know who it is that's what they do
that's their job that's why I wanted to
thank the healthcare workers and
everybody thinks the healthcare workers
but it's not just the healthcare workers
it's all the people who've been out
there all this time making sure everyone
else could stay home they have higher
infection rates they're getting paid a
minimal amount of money they have
families at home too that are suffering
but they're getting up every day and
they're doing their job so as we talk
about reopening protect and respect the
essential workers they need testing they
need equipment they're putting their
lives on the line protect and respect
the essential workers public
transportation we've kept running
because they need it to get to work
that's why public transport
continued we talked early on about
closing down public transportation they
said forget it that's how the nurses are
getting to work that's how the orderlies
are getting to work nobody will be in a
hospital nobody will be there to deliver
the food nobody will be in the power
plant to keep the lights on nobody will
be at the telecommunications Department
public transportation is vital for them
well then make sure public
transportation is safe and disinfected
the New York Times New York Daily News
ran a story today on the public
transportation in New York City and
their front page is a picture of a
subway car filled with homeless people
and their belongings a sec respect the
essential workers that is disgusting
what is happening on those subway cars
it's disrespectful to the essential
workers who need to ride the subway
system upstate New York need to ride the
buses to get to work they deserve better
and they will have better we have to
have a public transportation system that
is clean where the trains are
disinfected you have homeless people on
trains it's not even safe for the
homeless people to be on trains no face
masks you have this whole outbreak we're
concerned about homeless people so we
let them stay on the trains without
protection in this epidemic of of the
kovat virus no we have to do better than
that and we will and we will learn from
this and will be better from this
because we are New York tough and tough
me is not just tough because tough is
easy it's smart and it's disciplined and
it's unified and it's loving and that's
who we are
and that's what we are and that's why we
got through this
as well as we have thus far together
because of our values because of our
respect our dignity mutuality our love
for one another are willing to sacrifice
and because we're fortunate where we
have many many heroes in our midst
not because they have medals on their
uniforms but because they have honor in
their souls and they have strengthened
their character and they have dignity
and pride in themselves and because they
show up every day every day to make sure
everyone is protected and they have to
be at the top of the list they're going
to be at the top of the list in the next
iteration of whatever this is they're
going to be at the top of the list at
the Golden Gate but they deserve our
respect and protection here and they're
going to get it
our lakeside towns when you think about
summer Central New York in the summer my
estimation is an attractive nuisance how
can these things go on yeah breaks my
heart but they can't unless it's done
statewide and unless it's done not just
statewide but in with our neighboring
states we had a situation in Connecticut
where they had certain things open that
we didn't have open they had waterside
parks just what you mentioned and
Connecticut called and said I have all
New York license plates in my parking
lot a people will get in the car and
drive several hours to go somewhere look
if you open the State Fair this year you
did you'd have the highest
attendance we ever had that I can
guarantee you but it wouldn't be good
everything is about reducing density so
it would have to be statewide parks
beaches water side attractions that
would have to be statewide or whatever
region did it without the others you
would have a massive infusion of people
from everywhere and that's then density
and density is the problem that is a no
unless it was done statewide in
collaboration with the other neighboring
states right we do almost everything
together with Connecticut in New Jersey
or at least we know what they're doing
and the consequences of what they're
doing but can you open the State Fair
unless the entire state is at a point
where it's opened I don't believe so
look it's something we work at everyday
it's not a New York problem it's a
nationwide problem the number of
unemployed hit an all-time high they all
called the local unemployment office in
the state every state is dealing with
this I talked to the governor's on on
joint conference calls every state is
overwhelmed and trying to design new
technology and new apps and new this our
state actually is doing much much better
than the other states in how many people
haven't been able to sign up we have
over 1,000 people working on phones and
technology it's even more now right
3,000 people hired just to man phones
and the website etc so we have the
number down dramatically but it was just
a sheer function of quantity and volume
now good news bad news
yes it's frustrating as heck good news
is the check it doesn't cost you any
money you will get the check for the
same period of time but your point is
right you are without that check until
you get signed up but the numbers are
way down Melissa do you remember dealing
with this crisis the problem is that as
we get the backlog down in the previous
weeks that continues to build you know
we're still getting claims in real time
right now we're down to around 400,000
outstanding claims the majority of those
are the pandemic unemployment insurance
itself contractors the gig employs
people who are out of work because their
kids schools are closed which is
something that the state has never dealt
with before that was new as a result of
the cares act that was done at the end
of March
and so the Department of Labor as the
governor said we now have 3000 people
that are working on this issue and
they're gonna keep working at it till
everybody gets their money the one thing
I will say is the governor did an
executive order that said that you can't
be evicted for the 90 days and obviously
that's something that will extend going
forward if that's necessary so while
folks are waiting to get this process
and while we get through this at least
they know they can't be evicted from
their homes and they will get the back
pay back to the first day that they were
do it and we understand and we
sympathize and we're asking people to
please remain patient and we're doing
everything we can to resolve the problem
so that's what we were aware of as of
yesterday morning we did a further
investigation it appears there was one
mailing that was the problem weird
literally two pieces of paper when they
were printed and collated were stuck
together and then that caused the whole
mailing to be off and so we haven't
identified the specific number they're
looking at that right now but added out
of an abundance of caution everyone
whose forms were printed and mailed that
day are gonna receive free credit
monitoring for an entire year and
they're having their claims prioritized
so they are working on that as of
yesterday morning that was the number we
fear that number is higher but we have
isolated the one mailing that it was
impacted from I can get that information
too it was the end of last week
today what we did I gave concepts more
yesterday today I actually gave the
numbers and the data the actual steps to
a reopening plan we said that we'll look
at regions May 15th state goes on
unpause
we aren't pause unpause that's about two
weeks the CDC guidelines says the
climbing cases for the preceding two
weeks so if we see the cases continuing
to go down we get to November 15th we'll
have met CDC guidelines in some parts of
the state not new you're sitting at
downstate unless a miracle happens
please please but so then you'd have
regions which would meet the CDC
guidelines like some of the other states
have met CDC guidelines they could then
plan a reopening the question will be
what is a reopening plan right
everybody's talking about reopening I'm
gonna have a reopening plan
what is it reopening plan there was no
such thing as a reopening plan nobody's
done it before so we went back we
studied every reopening plan spoke to
every international expert who went
through this epidemic wave second wave
flu season and actually came up with 12
steps which are a reopening plan with
metrics with data here are the numbers
and this is what has to be in place to
reopen and regions that in two weeks
have reduced rates by the CDC guidelines
these would be the reopening plans that
we have to have in place their regional
which means those counties would have to
coordinate on the county
responsibilities the state has to
coordinate certain responsibilities the
federal government has responsibilities
here they're providing supplies for the
testing because the testing has been a
big problem so this is the probably most
specific reopening plan with
data that I have seen and I've went
through many of these but it's a very
fact-based data-driven reopening plan
for regions that would keep them safe
and allow the economy to reopen in
phases the I was on that call the he's
talking to States when you talk to the
governor's you have 50 governors you
have 50 different situations right you
have some states that have a de minimis
problem and then you have me on the
phone who has the worst problem in the
country so some states are reopening if
a state is reopening then it would make
sense for some states to reopen schools
I don't know how you really reopen
businesses statewide without reopening
schools right because schools primarily
they educate our children as a practical
matter many people go to work because
their kids are in school if the kids are
not in school now you have a childcare
issue so for those states that makes
sense we're going to have a decision on
schools we have all schools in the state
closed we'll have a decision the end of
this week what we're going to do on
schools and then on summer schools
[Music]
and can't tell you what September looks
like I could guess but the guest doesn't
help anything we have to see where we
are I have a college student at home it
was supposed to graduate this year and
she's taking her course courses remotely
they don't plan any graduation they
don't plan any ceremony
so that's we'd have to figure out
September before we get there but we
have a long way between here and
September whatever rules would apply to
SUNY I would imagine apply to private
schools unless you know private school
can always make their own decisions
Glens Falls nope because they're in the
capital district yeah we have we when we
were in the midst of this we were
worried about the hospital capacity so
we did a couple of things we mandated
that every hospital add 50 percent
capacity so we went from 50,000 beds in
our system about 53,000 to about 75,000
beds we were looking at a projection of
120,000 hospital beds needed we only had
50 we went to 75 with a 50% additional
and then we said no elective surgery so
you don't fill those beds with elective
surgery that can be postponed I like to
by definition not life-threatening
the some regions of the state where the
numbers have come down you can allow
elective surgery again in those
hospitals because you don't have a
capacity issue some parts of the state
we still worry about a capacity issue
and we don't want to wind up in a
situation where hospitals say we can't
take any kovat patients because we have
beds filled with elective surgery but it
depends on the region you are in in
upstate New York but dr. Milano's knows
this better than either as the governor
said it depends on the region today
there will be some guidance going out
for those regions that can resume
elective surgery that the governor
announced last week particularly
prioritizing key surgeries that were put
off for several weeks that should be
coming today
capital district region still has a
capacity issue western New York has a
capacity issue central New York I don't
know do you know central New York will
have guidance because they've fallen
under the capacity threshold so all the
regions will be notified if you're above
the threshold below the threshold and
then receive guidance based upon where
they sit right now with in relation to
what the number of Kovac cases they do
have in their region so central New York
he's saying can resume elective surgery
because their number their capacity
number is lower the number of cases they
have is lower western New York Capital
District that's not the case we're
talking about regions of New York right
so different regions are in a different
place downstate New York is one of the
most hard-hit places on the globe let
alone in the state of New York or the
nation but look not downstate New York
also had nine eleven downstate New York
also had superstorm sandy yeah you will
take a there will be a disturbance to
the economy I have no doubt but we will
come back in downstate New York upstate
New York again some of the reasons in
upstate New York are much like other
states that was that slide I showed you
so we can be at about the same place
that they are but I'm not going to trade
off economics for life and death right
public health comes first life comes
first thinking about my grandfather you
still have to say you know if we have
our health anything else we can figure
out but you have to have your health you
know if you're ever in a situation with
yourself got for a bit or a loved one
where they give you a really devastating
diagnosis
you see how fast everything else becomes
irrelevant it's just gone you know if
you have your health you can figure out
anything else if you don't have your
health nothing else matters let's take
one more both you have county health
departments that technically have
traceurs or people who do this function
on a much lower level now but you have
County Health Department's you have
State Health Department officials and
then we're going to have to hire people
also this is something that no one has
ever done before and Mayor Bloomberg
former mayor of New York City is gonna
help us design a system do the training
but it's gonna be a collaborative so if
you said central New York if you look at
those numbers central New York would
need about 150 traceurs that would be
you look at the counties in that region
how many people can do tracing who are
now employees of the health department's
governments in that region you don't
have to be a Health Department person to
be a tracer how many state employees and
then how many do we have to hire to put
that system together
I don't believe we found any we haven't
had any complaints I'm sure you know
there are 600 nursing homes so I'm sure
there were complaints out there that I
haven't heard but normally when you have
a significant number I hear about it and
I haven't heard anything about it
[Music]
well the they have a right to know and
that is a responsibility of the nursing
home they have no they have the nursing
home has to inform family members of the
status of a person in a nursing home and
that we can help with and the Attorney
General is investigating Department of
Health is investigating also what's
really happening on nursing homes is
what we feared from the get-go right we
were introduced to this virus in the
state of Washington in a nursing home
this virus is an efficient effective
predator and the virus preys on the
vulnerable and the vulnerable are
primarily elderly people people with a
compromised immune system and a nursing
home is ground zero for this virus
period it is a congregate facility of
vulnerable people and to stop the virus
from getting in where every staff member
who walks in they have to take their
temperature etc testing etc but it just
takes one person one facility person one
nurse one orderly one doctor one
anything to walk in there with a virus
and then it is fire through dry grip and
dry grass in that nursing home that is
you look at the people who have passed
with this virus predominantly senior
citizens predominantly people with a
compromised immune system that is where
this virus goes and it is frightening it
is frightening and if you have a loved
one in a nursing home yes it is
frightening
one more certain well the way the plan
would work is you have you have built-in
monitoring mechanisms right you have a
bill thing I would say governor but I
don't want to say that governor can be a
limiting device you have a built-in
circuit breaker if you go above seventy
percent capacity on your hospital's
circuit breaker so if you hit flu season
and people start to come in for the flu
and you hit that 70 percent threshold
then circuit breaker you have to do
something different you're in the red
zone if the infection rate for colvett
goes over 1.1 which is one person has it
and it transfers to more than one person
one point one circuit breaker because
you're off to the races at one point one
that is what they call outbreak status
we're down by like point eight now so
it's a tight margin of error point eight
to one point one but those would be two
built-in circuit breakers and they are
afraid of the flu season for two reasons
the flu season takes up hospital
capacity the flu season takes up testing
capacity we're working to get all these
labs to do Co fit testing well what the
labs normally do they do all the flu
testing seasonal but they do all the flu
testing well if you have all the labs
doing covert testing what happens when
flu season comes you're gonna have to
reduce the number of coded tests so they
are worried about the flu season and
then if you get to a flu season and you
start to feel achy and your
sneezing and you're coughing you're
going to say Oh either I had the flu or
I have kovat and having the flu is one
thing having kovat is something else
you're gonna run to the emergency room
and now they worry about hospital
capacity again that's just with the flu
season that's without the so-called
second wave with the word about with the
second wave is you look at the 1918
pandemic flu pandemic it came in waves
the first one and then the virus mutated
and came back stronger so could the
virus mutate and come back stronger
maybe that's what the second wave is
that's why I say it's so important when
we're doing the retrospective here what
happens next time China says I have a
flu I have a virus or South Korea says I
have a virus is it going to take the
international community and the federal
agencies two months to figure out that
we're in trouble you know I think the
attitude has to be a flu a virus
anywhere is a virus everywhere that's
the only safe operating principle right
well it was in China on Monday it could
be here today well we're not so sure we
don't yeah but it could be right so but
that's the second wave they're afraid of
and then the flu I have to go back to
Albany thank you very much
we'll be governing on well the parents
will follow facts because parents are
worried about the safe and health of
their safety and health of their child
the state the state emergency powers
govern over the 700 school districts so
whatever we'll do we do will be binding
on the school districts
the workers who've been